hi I'm Erik Bosse and the ventures in
video we're still bringing up a lot of
questions everyone wondering how
Avengers 4 could resolve a NASA's effort
to snap away half the universe and what
better way to fix that effort than with
maximum effort that's right this theory
going around that Deadpool might make a
crossover in to Avengers 4 now sure this
may not be a new theory but recent
events have made this impossibility ever
so slightly more plausible Disney is
getting closer and closer to outbidding
comcast for Fox's movie properties
meaning that all the Marvel characters
that Fox owns Deadpool Cable the x-men
Fantastic Four and others could soon
join the MCU owned by Disney the
Avengers guardians of galaxy black
panther and the rest but what exactly is
this Deadpool crossover theory well
let's break it down and spoiler warning
in case your patient dork who refuses to
look at set photos okay
the mysterious piece of evidence that
started all of this was a series of
leaked set photos from Avengers 4 now
there are quite a few things odd about
this why is cap back in his classic
Avengers 1 era stars in striped suit who
invited ant-man to the grown-ups table
by the way you may have seen a
photoshopped version of one of these
photos showing Deadpool on set with the
same silly looking mocap dots on his
suit and this is fake a well-done fake
but think really the details people
caught on to were these wristwatch like
devices strapped around their hands
where are these things
why do each of them have them while some
of observe that these devices resembled
the time travel device that appeared in
Deadpool 2 the one used by cable and
also by Deadpool during the movie's
awesome post credits sequence now if you
watch my breakdown of Deadpool 2 you'll
know that that device was based on a
real-life Carl F cougar or watched known
from John wick too it had more of a
steampunk eerie design but it's trapped
on cables arm not too differently from
the devices on Tony and Kat so the idea
is that Avengers 4 could feature
Deadpool and cable crossing over into
the reality of the Avengers lending them
a time-travel device that allows them to
rewind the clock and fix the timeline
before Thanos similar to the way
Deadpool turn back time to prevent
Vanessa's death and is a own x-men
origins self cool yes this theory is a
stretch to be the biggest wrench is that
we are
years away if ever from Deadpool in the
Avengers appearing in a movie together
regardless of any Disney Foxx deal in
recent months Avengers infinity war and
Avengers 4 and Deadpool 2 took place in
different movie universes the movies
were written developed and shot by two
independent film studios working in
extreme contract protected secrecy over
a period of years with their stories
locked in long before Fox announced its
sale and a possibility of Deadpool
joining the MCU could even enter the
imagination and Avengers 4 wrapped
principal production before any deals
between Disney and Fox began any kind of
negotiations so the filmmakers of
Deadpool 2 would have no reason to
conspire with the Avengers team to set
up a piece of technology to tie their
separate universes together that's just
not how movies are made and before we
start saying that Josh Brolin could have
been a link he after all played both
cable and fan oh so sure he had access
to both scripts Roland did not write for
direct or produce either of these movies
they just pan him the script and he
delivers and how if this Disney Foxx
merger does go through it would take
years for the Marvel team to figure out
how to even introduce Deadpool and the
x-men and the Fantastic Four into their
movie universe the Russo brothers have
hinted that they could be interested in
a Secret Wars movie that crosses over a
lot of the Marvel heroes and villains or
Marvel could reboots a lot of these
franchises the x-men or maybe do a true
adaptation of the Civil War event which
in the comics was way more epic than the
Captain America Civil War movie that we
saw heavily involved the x-men and
Fantastic Four but the follow up to
infinity war would just be too soon to
introduce Deadpool in his current Brian
Reynolds incarnation to the MCU however
I don't think it's totally crazy to see
a connection between these devices and
the set photos and the one Deadpool -
like cables time machine was designed to
resemble a literal clock a practical
representation of time like time itself
is already a pretty abstract concept and
when it comes to time travel filmmakers
and production designers are limited in
the imagery they can use to convey it to
the audience that's why in many movies
time machines look like actual clocks
even in Marvel's Doctor Strange the time
stone in the eye of agamotto manifests
as a circular spell over the users wrist
we're turning it counterclockwise for
Weins time and clockwise moves the
forward we saw Thanos do this at the end
of Infinity Ward to get the mine stone
from vision I'm just saying if the
Avengers and they set photos have
watched like devices on their hands it's
not the worst assumption in the world
that their time travel associated you
know honestly the more I stare at these
devices the more I think they might
actually be some kind of pimp tech
ant-man related Pym discs which can
shrink or grow objects can latch on to
anything and they're circular shaped a
lot like these things are remember cap
already has familiarity with them from
Civil War throw it at this the reason I
think this is check out Scott's hand the
device seems embedded in his glove
already like it's stitched in the ones
on Tony and cap are strapped on with
bands so I think these could have been
given to them by Scott perhaps some Pym
tech that allows them all to shrink
together and just to continue down this
theory rabbit hole maybe this team
shrinking could be how the Avengers
enter the quantum realm a place remember
that Hank Pym described as a reality
where all concepts of time and space
become irrelevant I don't know if we
take that literally these devices could
be both Pym discs and time machines as I
guess in this theory in the MCU when you
get small you travel through time maybe
but here's a question for you guys
if Deadpool could ever cross over into
the MCU and join the Avengers in their
fight against Thanos do you think his
regeneration power is strong enough to
bring Thanos down comment with your
thoughts down below or tweet me directly
at EA us and like this video share it
around subscribe to new rock stars for
all of our explanations of Marvel
related theories even when they seem
just plain silly thanks for watching bye